this evening we'll be taking a look at
my round eight game I played earlier
today the game started 10 hours ago I
was playing against a pretty strong
junior from Canada I'll try and
pronounce the name
Olivier Kenta chiku rate' I was black
and just because of the tournament
standings I was I mean I was clearly
playing for a win and I did manage to
win apologies for the spoiler but it put
me in or puts me in good good standing
going into tomorrow yeah the game was
actually pretty smooth I felt like the
opening went well
I got a comfortable position early on
with black and then then the conversion
I think was very smooth as well so take
a look it was an Enzo Indian earlier in
the tournament I played a a two nights
Tango against Rochelle Wu I spent a good
deal of time preparing this before the
tournament but I decided not to use it
in this game I wanted to play something
a bit more solid so I played e6 Knight
c3 Bishop to b4 nimzo-indian this is not
the easiest opening to learn or study
just because white has so many options
and there's so many different ways like
the position can transform there's also
so many ways that black can play in
terms of like which pawns to move so
it's a very flexible opening and I mean
to play the nihms o for either color you
have to basically learn like a whole a
whole set of openings not just one line
so that's why some people like in this
position they avoid the nihms oh they
play like Knight f3 or g3 which are kind
of the main alternatives but we went
into this he played III the so called
rumens teen variation this is probably
the most common way to meet the nihms oh
and then I played b6
is the first kind of new move for me in
the past I've castled and like I usually
go for d5 but p6 has has an interesting
idea to it and he played night GE 2
which I I was expecting and the point of
night G 2 it looks weird at first
because the blocks in the bishop but
white simply wants to play a 3 and then
if I take my takes and why the voids the
double pawns on the queenside so I was
expecting this and I got to play the
line I prepared Bishop to a6 with a
simple idea of hitting the pawn pawns
not defended and white doesn't
necessarily want to play B 3 because
that weakens the knight on c3 so white
has a few options here there was
probably three main options there's a
three probably most common move there's
also Knight g3 and 9f four also playable
to defend with the bishop he played
Knight g3 in the game just to show the
mean lion if he does play a three I
would take then after it takes I would
play d5 and it's it's a solid variation
for black of ideas to try and trade off
LightSquared Bishop s' and if white
plays b3 and then very simply castling
and it's a game and white does have the
bishop pair up at this bishops locked in
so I was really just going for for
something solid but okay Knight g3 was
played castling and now Bishop to d3 so
here I just follow through with kind of
a main idea with Bishop a6 I play pawn
to d5 and we did trade takes takes take
sticks and then castling so so far this
is all pretty standard tell you where he
eights this is probably the most
flexible move I know I want to play rook
e8 I wasn't sure if I wanted to like go
for a 97 or go for a c5 Knight c6
so just being flexible then he plays f3
so
this is maybe like the first sign that
like he's committing to some some sort
of King site plans there's a few ideas
with this move the main idea is to
eventually play e4
another idea is to play tonight at 5 and
G for the drawback of f3 though and what
happened in the game is that I can
respond with c5 and this is very common
for especially Queen's pawn opening
whenever white plays off 3 c5 is very
thematic and the idea is it's very hard
for a white to play e4 because d4 is a
bit loose and actually for the rest of
the game like he never got a foreign and
the pawn just stayed on on e3 so I've a
feeling maybe f3 was as a slight
misjudgment of course he tried to like
justify it in the game I was feeling a
maybe a slightly better approach for
white would be a 3 I kicked the bishop I
was planning to move d6 or f8 let's say
d6 then I thought like b4 and like
Bishop b2 rook c1 and put some pressure
on the C file maybe even played plum b5
at some points or even like Knight d5
rook c1 and I thought white should maybe
play a bit more positionally so f3 was
played play c5 and then he plays 92
after the game I was interviewed by by
Lenderman and lunderman was criticizing
this this move Knight ce2 he said it was
moving the knight in the wrong direction
which is perhaps correct like the knight
should probably stay on c3 and pressure
d5 I play knight c6 a3 and now now
important move because I don't want to
play Bishop a5 so I want to keep the
bishop like back on this diagonal so
first I play c4 hitting the Queen Queen
c2 Bishop d6
and I was pretty content with the setup
it's still difficult for a white to play
E for the e4 it doesn't work now because
uh the central pawns come under fire
just take on g3 and I'm winning d4 or a4
or both so I play Bishop d6 plays 9.5
Bishop f8 then he moved back to c3 so
maybe as a slight waste of time I play a
six and I was being patient here like I
want to play b5 and maybe someday even
before trade off and get the knight to
d3 maybe also like B 5 and then a 5 and
B 4 and just storm with the pawns
another idea with a6 is to play rook a7
and just bring this rook so the
half-open file which we do see a bit
later so he plays G for a slightly
delayed grab expanding on the Kings side
I'm trying to support the Knights so
it's clear that he was maybe trying to
orchestrate some attack and the idea of
g5 is is slightly annoying because this
mites would need to find a reasonable
Square but then I realized g5 isn't so
annoying oh the question from drip Man
13 do you think you lost a tempo by not
just playing Bishop f8 right away that's
actually a good point to bring up I was
very well aware that after Bishop d6 9f5
hits a bishop and I did this
intentionally I knew I could play Bishop
I faith in one move but I figured that
with the Nylund f5 White is also going
to lose time because I'll eventually
play g6 and the knight will most likely
be kicked back so yeah my bishops
content here I would eat ideas of g6 and
Bishop g7 I thought like overall the
position is is very like harmonious for
black like still ideas of this Queen
side storm still ideas of this and I
thought my King was it was quite safe
so night c3a 6
g4b 5 just improving um so I do allow g5
g5 was played some people are just
really happy when they see g5 and I play
Knight to h5 and the night looks kind of
awkward here because it's it's
completely restricted like it can't move
to any of these squares but at the same
time it's kind of an outpost like I'll
play g6 and the Knights very stable and
this light is also kind of stuck and the
g5 pawn is hit so I figured this is uh
this is okay so Queen and g2 and then g6
hitting the the Knights and then the
next move that was played I I kind of
overlooked from whites I was expecting
Knight G wait what it was like expecting
night g3 I just when the pawn maybe I
was expecting Knight h4 or Knight h6 but
I think okay my opponent played the best
move Queen g4 making it so I can't
really take the night because my pawn
structure is hideous and then I played
rook to a7 so the line I want to show is
I was considering some move okay first
of all I can't play Queen d7 this is a
tragic blunder night h6 wins my queen
but I was considering Queen c8 and then
I was like kind of dreaming about a line
where white plays Knight g3 I take the
Queen he takes back I take on g3 he
takes back and he has triple G pawns and
then someday in the far-off future I'll
play like this he'll take I'll play this
he'll play g5 second g5 I'll play this
he'll take and then he can play g5 once
more and I don't know why I was thinking
about this during the game but I was
just trying to figure out like the most
number of times you can play pawn g5 in
one game
because three is a lot anyway um what
happened the game I play rock a seven
being patients I figured that why not
make an improving move this is maybe one
of the one of the pieces which wasn't
doing anything on on eight I someday
still want to swing it over so he plays
Knight g3 we trade and then I played
Bishop to g7 it's feeling very
comfortable here
ideas of just improving like I figured
my like all my pieces can find squares
actually in this position I was
beginning to imagine like my ideal setup
because there's a number of pieces which
can still be improved mainly the bishop
the Knights the rook and maybe the Queen
so I was imagining bringing the Knight
to f5 having the Bishop on g7 and having
the rook on e7 and if I achieve the
setup then there's a lot of pressure on
e3 and e4 and Y will have a very hard
time playing efore still because d4 is
as attacked multiple times so I start
with Bishop g7 he plays King g2 so the
one sort of Trump that White has in the
positions I have Pope in each file so
there were like very clear ideas of just
destroying me on each seven however it
like even if like gets three moves in a
row and wins h7 I just play king FA then
the king is actually still pretty safe
so it wasn't the biggest concern I think
there is more more emphasis on the
center
I play ninety seven pleased with this
move just idea of Knight 9.5 he plays f4
f4 was a dispositional blunder it's not
a great thing when you have a dark
squared Bishop and all your pawns are on
dark squares but when you play that five
there's actually like a very clear idea
or when he played that for there's a
clear idea that he wants to play Queen
a3 and then g4 and then f5 and then
maybe even f6 maybe open that file so if
he gets a few moves it can actually be
annoying especially like once g4 and
that v is coming it's not the easiest
thing to deal with okay so I play Knight
f5 hitting the pawn and now it's not so
easy for whites please Queen f3 hitting
this pawn and actually when I play
Knight f5 I I had to calculate so I had
to calculate 9f5
Queen f3 because I have to worry about
d5 and I was calculating rookie 7 Knight
takes d5 there's actually a really nice
move in that line so let me play this on
the board I play rook e7 and this will
be a question for the chats because
rookie 7 does allow Knight takes d5
hitting the rook also defending the pawn
a question is black to move what is the
best move for black how can black punish
this this Knight move so the chats is
still contemplating lot of people saying
Queen takes d5 this blender is a queen I
think Queen takes d5 I know you want to
play Knight takes III but this Bishop
takes c3 few people saying taking on e3
taking on the e3 doesn't work if Knight
or a rook takes III there's just night
tix III sufficiently defended okay so
congratulations to alex looong lovehate
chess tristan so leery and rar 2040
finding the right move and now
combinatorial rookie 4 it's not like
it's not the most forcing type of move
it's not a capture it's not any sort of
check but it does make a threat it
obstructs the Queen from defending the
knight and in doing so I'm just
threatening to take the Knights and
remember the light is tied down to
defending this pawn and if I can win the
e3 pawn oh when the d4 pawn
so the position can actually crumble
really quickly here for whites the night
has to move somewhere moves back to c3 I
could even take with a rook here can
take with night or rook and then things
just simplify in blacks favor Bishop
takes takes I'm winning this guy on f1
and then I'll win d4 so I actually went
upon an end and just have a great
position so I had to see that know if I
had to see that but I I saw the idea of
rookie four when I play Knight f5
ensuring that that I can play rook e7
and white will be forced to be passive
so this is what happened he did not take
on d5 because of rookie force so he saw
it too
he plays mighty 191 it it looks so
depressing but it's the best attempt in
the position trying to just hold on and
like after he played it I was feeling I
mean I was feeling a really good here
and then he played my t1 and then I
realized like I still need a plan
like white super solid here and it still
takes work to break through and white
actually has a clear plan here white
wants to eventually play g4 f5 has to
start with maybe the king g1 at rookie
h1 just to deal with night h4 so the
ball is in my court and the the idea I
came up with was was actually very
satisfying and it it transpired in the
game and I managed I think I managed to
play the most accurate continuation so I
think what I'll do is I'll show the next
move and then I'll have the chat find
the move after so I play Queen g7 and
white plays rift h1 and I think this is
like very critical position because like
black bloc's pieces are fully optimized
and I need some like further idea also
White has this idea of g4
five later at six maybe ideas of meeting
me so I don't have like unlimited time
so again for the chats black to move and
find the best move and honestly this is
a type of move okay you can guess but it
does require like calculation it took me
like several minutes to be fully
confident that this is actually working
if you're watching on YouTube in the
future and you want more time without
any clues feel free to pause the video
but let's see what's suggested we have
okay we have both options of taking on
d4 we have rookie for we have 96 we have
g5 which is slightly illegal Bishop e3
also illegal hopefully there's more
legal move suggested than illegal moves
we have rookie 2 also illegal resign
that's legal but it's wrong okay so
there's a good handful of people that
have found found the move that I played
and the move that I played I actually
wanted to play a move earlier the move
is Bishop takes d4 and this will type of
move you can play just based on pure
intuition like after takes takes you can
see a beautiful night the rooks coming
in but it's also very forcing because I
hit the Queen and I follow up with more
initiative so just going back to this
position I really wanted to play Bishop
takes d4 here but I was having a hard
time evaluating like takes takes takes
and in Queen g4 and I thought the Queen
was active here I'd like two blacks
chances but I thought it was getting a
little bit murky
so this is why I played Queen d7 just
ensuring that when I do take on d4 white
doesn't have access to the g4 square and
it's actually hard for a white to deal
with this threat he can't play queen g4
obviously because Knight takes Knight
takes III maybe queen g4 could be
playable but it looks wrong but yeah the
main idea is to to control g4 and then
sac on g4 so what ended up happening was
was really nice because the Queen's
attacked and I continued like I think
for the rest of the game I continued
just throwing punches basically making
threats like rookie two on the horizon
Knight B 3 on the horizon this Queen is
actually a like almost trapped like the
only squares for the Queen are C 3 and F
1 F 2 runs into - rookie - so we played
Queen C 3 and what else to do whoa it's
chess bra in the chat Eric beating up on
Canadians I apologize but not really but
yeah yeah my opponent was Canadian so I
apologize if I made one of your
compatriots slightly sad but that's the
nature of chess I'm sure you'll get
revenge someday there's some Canadian
will get revenge on me I'm going to
Canada in like a few months so I guess I
have to watch my back
okay so queen c3 trying to do something
hit the Knights get the Queen safe I
play Knight b3 hitting the rook also
kind of tickling the bishop also
preparing d4 and actually when I
initially saw this line I was
calculating like d4 I thought the Queen
had to go to b5 I was calculating a5 and
the Queen's actually just trapped it's
just being like hugged by my pawns but I
missed actually that the Queen could go
back to f3
I missed it like a few moves in advance
so once we got this position I realized
d4 it's still good for luck but there is
there's actually a far better move here
at least in my opinion Queen f5 hitting
the rook also trapping the rook like the
rooks just trapped
there's no defense like why can't block
this a1 square is off-limits rookie to
still looming so I'm down a piece for
two pawns but I mean just massive
initiative lonely pawn asking why not
rookie - yeah rookie choose playable I
thought I could save it for later
because rookie to Knight f2 and it helps
them might develop and it also makes
white closer to connecting the rooks but
I'm sure rookie 2 is is also winning so
according on 5 he plays an f2 and then
that I play rookie - so I didn't take
the rook because taking the rook
actually it leads to messiness like
Knight g4 and then like he's threatening
mating ideas 96 King f8 Queen h8 would
be mates and I didn't want to calculate
this I would imagine black is still
winning somehow maybe like rook rook e2
followed by t4 but um I decided to play
rook e - now I just prevent any sort of
counter play the rook is still trapped
this bishop
can't move I mean white would like to
connect the rooks but Bishop has no
squares so he plays Queen f6 yeah this
is kind of a last-ditch effort the idea
with Queen f6 is actually interesting I
take on f2
maybe I should have had the chat find
this actually would this be a valid
question let me just show this line I
wanted to take on b1 but there's a
slightly tricky line which I just didn't
want to calculate which is rook takes h7
and like now I would think it's still
winning for black but like I need to be
meeting the king or somehow forcing that
Queen trade because white is ready to
meet me in multiple ways and if I take
this is oh this is not perpetual oh I
thought this is perpetual this is
winning for luck I forgot the Queen
defends g6 and my rook rook is defended
on eight so I could play King h8 check
here white has no more checks so yeah
even that trick didn't work but this was
a nice finish rook takes an f2 takes an
Queen c2 and when I play Queen c2 I I
saw the final mate it's made sin like 7
I forgot an exact number it moves
somewhere in the range of like 16 moves
King f1 Queen d1 King G to check King to
f3 maybe this is a good moment for the
the chat yeah let me give this as a
final question to the chat
black to move find find the force mates
I mean it looks really good
how should black proceed
I'll give credits to finding the first
move in the variation but I'll give
extra credits to finding the whole
mating sequence it should be mate in one
- oh it should just be made in three
yeah very important in this position not
some blunder the Queen because moves I
mean a move like rook
for example rookie six might look fun
attack the king and the Queen but then
there's rook takes t1 so the best move
is rook e1 obstruct the rook from
attacking the Queen attack the King
Andromeda said The Lion King F - Queen
e2 mates which is correct but in John
John Davis said the line King G - Queen
e2 king h3 and then rip takes h1 mates
the key resigns like one move before he
resigned in this position so it was a
nice game I mean in the final position
I'm down a rook for two pawns not that
it matters but there are some nice
sacrifices like the two sacrifices in
this game where Bishop takes d4 and then
rook takes f2 with some forcing forcing
chess and I think a nice theme in this
game was the fact that I didn't really
go for any attack straightaway I just
was patient like slowly improving the
position got my structure got like every
single piece where it wanted to go and
then then the tactics flowed nicely
sometimes this is this is typical in
chess where like before you can actually
launch an attack you want to make sure
your pieces are in good squares and
unfortunately for my opponent like these
these pieces never got in the game
so after the game we were saying that
like maybe white should have been a bit
more patience like even in this position
starting with Bishop t2 rook e1 because
white also had time to improve so that
was my game um I hope you guys enjoyed
that if you want to do your own analysis
so I'll leave the study link in the chat
again for the people watching on YouTube
in the future also hope you guys enjoyed
that I'll be I'll be back with more
videos you can smash the subscribe
button if you haven't already and click
the bell and yeah I'll see you in the
future